There's an old saying:
God may have made the world,
but the Dutch made the Netherlands.
This is the Maeslant Barrier
and it's one part of the Delta Works,
a set of megastructures
that hold back the ocean
when high seas threaten
to flood this country.
This is one of the world's
largest movable structures,
a pair of 210-meter-long gates
designed to seal off
the main shipping route to Rotterdam port
and hold back storm surges.
Depending on whose
measurements you believe,
somewhere between a fifth and a third
of the Netherlands sits below sea level,
a lot of that reclaimed
from the ocean over years
through managing marshlands
and moving earth and pumping water.
There are areas of the Netherlands
described as "former islands",
and these gates are part
of the enormous system
that Dutch engineers built
to keep this country dry.
And a couple of hours northeast of here
is where they learned to do it.
This is just one part
of the 10 square kilometres
of Waterloopbos
and it was built when the
only way to simulate water
was to use water.
It's now a national monument
and nature is taking
back these structures,
these experiments.
- Waterloop means how the
flow runs through a system,
that is Waterloop in Dutch.
Over here, we mostly did
what we call model studies,
so basically simulating nature
at a certain, smaller scale.
The whole area started more or less
after the second World War,
so around 1950,
when there was a big demand
for model studies related
to the Delta Works in the
southwest part of the Netherlands.
It was for the Delta Works
but we also did many
studies all over the world,
studies of the harbour of Libya,
harbours in Tunisia,
harbours in the Far East, Hong Kong.
The main reason for building
the Waterloopbos here is
that we needed a lot of space
for the models
because, around 1950, all
the models were outdoor.
And another thing is you need water.
Where we are standing here is basically
the bottom of the former Zuiderzee.
So we are here standing at the level,
let's say, minus two or minus three metres
below mean sea level.
Here we have a natural water drop
of about five metres
so we just have to open the gate
at that part of the wood
and the water will flow
freely through this area.
We are standing in what
we call the Delta flume,
an enormous rectanglar box, so to say,
and now you see more an artist's
impression of this flume
with certain sections cut out and placed
perpendicular to the original flume wall.
In this flume, the studies are related
to the design of breakwaters.
These breakwaters are enormously costly,
in the order of, let's say,
100 million euros.
If you take a section out
of your breakwater
and then scale it down
to about one to five,
and test it here.
I've been in meetings where they fight
for every centimetre of the block.
Well, if we propose, let's say,
that the blocks will be one metre,
they ask, could not be the block
95 centimetres
or 96 centimetre or 97 centimetres
because that is money.
Each centimetre you could use
on a block is money
and therefore this was one
of the cash cows of Delta Hydraulics,
doing these studies,
which are expensive,
but still cheap in the
design of a big breakwater.
At the moment, the Waterloopbos
is a kind of tourist attraction.
The upcoming of the computer,
that was one of the main reasons
that this area was left around 2000.
We do excursions for tourists
to see how we operated
the old, outdoor models
and this flume is handed over
to the natural monument
organisation about two years ago.
So although we left the territory in 2000,
this flume was still
operational for about 15 years
because you cannot easily replace
this flume to another place.
- The Water Act, part of Dutch law,
requires the government
to maintain flood defences.
And it establishes a
maximum risk that's allowed.
So there are parts of the Netherlands
that, in law, it must take
a one-in-10,000-year
weather event to flood.
The trouble is that the predictions for
what "one in 10,000 years" involves
keep getting worse.
Since they were completed in 1997,
the gates of the Maeslant Barrier
have only been closed in defence twice,
but that's going to become
more common in future.
Flood defences that were
researched here were designed
to protect the cities and towns
that people already lived in
but with those defences in place,
people kept building
and the consequences of
failure keep growing.
The Dutch are going to have
to keep making the Netherlands
for a long time yet.